so just imagine this entire parking lot
pretty much filled with one mirror for a
giant telescope a telescope that will be
the biggest telescope on earth yeah so
it's a it's a it's a little bit of a
fudge because it's not a symbol look
actually you get used that much it's a
circle with a line through it it's
actually more of an engineering symbol
than a physicists symbol generally
speaking in astronomy bigger is better
when it comes to diameter all the
telescope is is a big light bucket we
just sit out there with a mirror and
collect photons as they come in from
astronomical objects let's take the
story back to the beginning and again as
with most things in astronomy it goes
back to Galileo Galileo's first
observations with the telescope he was
using a refracting telescopes or a
telescope with lenses in it and the
lenses were a few inches across but
basically with optical telescopes we
don't talk about lenses anymore we talk
about mirrors mostly and the nice thing
about mirrors is you can make a lot
bigger than you can make lenses so you
can build bigger and bigger telescopes
the first telescope that I ever had some
involvement with was when I was a summer
student in Victoria in Canada and that
was at the Dominion Astrophysical
Observatory and they have a lovely
telescope there and it's 1.8 metres in
diameter now at the time it was built
back in around 1918 I believe it was for
a short period of time the largest
telescope on earth it was temperamental
there actually was an official stick
next to it with which you had to hit
some of the equipment to make it work
and so then we graduate up into what we
might think of as medium sized
telescopes and these are telescopes that
are maybe the mirror is maybe 4 meters
in diameter
so those include telescopes that I've
been to include the Canada France Hawaii
telescope in Hawaii so of another very
nice summer experience working at that
telescope and something like the William
Herschel telescope which is a British
telescope in lipoma
again a very nice holiday destination
you probably see a theme coming in here
we tend to build telescopes where the
weather is it's good some of some of the
life of an astronomer is fair
hard so when you go to Hawaii you may
think of beaches and palm trees but the
telescopes in Hawaii on top of the
mountain Mauna Kea they're at 14,000
feet your oxygen-deprived it looks like
the surface of Mars you're above the
clouds you're jet-lagged and you're
working at night so yes you do get to go
to the beach at the end of your
observing run but that's probably after
five or six nights of very very very
hard work well a Hubble is kind of the
anomaly here because I said in most
cases bigger is better
but the Hubble mirror is only 2.5 meters
in diameter so what's so special about
the Hubble well first of all it's in
space so it's not sitting at the bottom
of this really murky moving atmosphere
but not only the size of the mirror
matters but the quality of the mirror
and the mirror on Hubble was ground to
precision that I don't think has been
equalled it was incredibly incredibly
precise of course that's a whole nother
story because it was precise in in the
wrong way and had to be fixed
thanks to an accident in the measuring
but it was accurate too I think one
fiftieth of a human hair so with the
Hubble it might not be the biggest
telescope on the block but it certainly
got some of the sharpest eyesight yeah
so then the next class of telescopes are
something around the 6th 8th 10 metre in
diameter for their mirror so I've used
the Magellan telescope in Chile so I
visited there and stood underneath that
mirror which measurement measures six
point five meters in diameter which is
pretty big but we also have lots of
telescopes around the world that have
eight meter mirrors and that's kind of
the limit if you want to build a single
lens or a single mirror you can build a
mirror eight meters across but that's
really pushing the technology because
you've got to build a mirror eight
meters across which is optically perfect
so that can actually focus the light so
it has to be figured to within a
fraction of a wavelength of light and
it's eight meters across it's a from an
engineering point of view it's really
pushing the limits for example if you
take a mirror like that and then you
point it in a different direction which
of course is one of the things you
to do with the telescope the mirror sags
and so you actually need to have the
whole thing actively controlled with
little pressure pads behind to push it
back into shape so you've got all these
they're sort of active stuff going on
holding you into shape
so even today the biggest telescopes
which are sort of 10 11 12 meters in
diameter aren't single mirrors we've
gone to this system where you use our
whole series of little segments so you
have lots of hexagonal segments that all
kind of join together like a honeycomb
we have the amusingly named VLT which is
the Very Large Telescope which is
actually four eight meter telescopes in
Chile we the next telescopes the really
big ones are gonna be a lot lot bigger
than that so the one of the first ones
that was bandied about was the the owl
the overwhelmingly large telescope and
that was that was proposed to be a
hundred meters in diameter so for
various reasons that's probably not
going to come about
so we've downgraded slightly to instead
of the overwhelmingly large telescope
the extremely large telescope I'm afraid
we sort of gave up giving things
exciting names some time ago it'll
probably end up with a more interesting
name when it actually gets built but for
the moment that's what it's known as and
that's going to have a mirror that will
be 42 metres in diameter so it's a whole
series of more than a thousand
individual segments that are all going
to be joined together to make a single
mirror effectively that's 42 metres in
diameter which as you might imagine it's
going to collect an absolute shedload of
light so we're gonna be singing able to
see things which we stand no chance at
all of seeing at the moment we'll be
able to see planets like the earth
orbiting around other nearby stars and
even be able to study the atmospheres of
those planets to figure out whether
there's life on them we'll be able to
see stars in other galaxies where at the
moment we can just see kind of the fuzzy
blur of light we're going to be able to
see galaxies on the other side of the
universe on the kind of accuracy where
currently we can only see nearby
galaxies so it's going to completely
revolutionize astronomy 42 metres 42
metres should we should we try so one
easy measurement I have is the computer
that goes on my bike so we're going to
go outside and I'm gonna get on my bike
and see if we can measure approximately
42 metres somewhere in the parking lot
and that's the sad thing these poor
photons of light they've been traveling
across the Gulf of space for you know 10
years hoping some astronomers going to
catch them and they you know they run
the splat into the roof of your house
and that's it it's all over so we'll
catch some of them I mean even with a
mirror 42 metres in diameter we're still
not going to catch very many of them but
it's a much bigger bucket than we've had
in the past so we're gonna come collect
a lot more light than we ever have
before okay so I've got my measuring
instrument here which is my bike and I
have a little wireless bike computer
that just sits on here so I'm gonna
reset that now and we're going to try to
see if we can figure out just how big 42
meters actually is that's still it's an
interesting question because obviously
there are kind of astronomical reasons
as to why you might want to put in
particular places for example there's
some things you can only see from the
southern hemisphere there's some things
you can only see from the northern
hemisphere so that's one issue you want
to put it somewhere dark because you
want to you know you don't want light
pollution to mess up your your images
but equally actually these things
consume rather a large amount of power
so their peak they can use as much power
as a small town so you need somewhere
where there's kind of the infrastructure
you can get a tricity to them you have
road access and all that kind of stuff
so you can't really pick somewhere
that's absolutely in the middle of
nowhere
and finally there's politics you know
you've got to put it somewhere that's
politically stable you don't want to put
it somewhere with it's gonna be a
revolution someone's going to
nationalize your telescope ten minutes
after you've built it and even you know
if you're trying to get money out to
someone it's usually easier to get money
if you say you're not going to build it
in your country so it's lots and lots of
things and it's still it'll I think it
will be finalized for the e-elt sometime
later this year but it's still open for
discussion at the moment okay so this
distance is 42 meters that I've just
traveled and that's going to be the
diameter of the mirror of the extremely
large telescope that's going to be built
so just imagine this entire parking lot
pretty much filled with one mirror for a
giant telescope a telescope that will be
the biggest telescope on earth